[Musique]
une des tâches difficiles pour l'auteur
de romans policiers
c'est d'arriver à disséminer des indices
çà et là qui sont à la fois évident sous
les yeux de chacun mais que personne ne
voie pour que à des mouvements dans le
livre et si possible plusieurs fois le
lecteur se disent mais c'est pas
possible
c'était sous mes yeux et je ne les ai
pas vus et ça c'est un sentiment qui est
plaisant pour l'acteur qui se dit
j'aurais pu le savoir
j'aurais pu voir j'ai pas été attentif
c'est de ma faute donc comment cacher
ses indices en général une facilité un
petit truc c'est de les cacher après
coup c'est à dire que il faut pas se
creuser la tête selon à dire je dois
absolument cacher un indice ici et là et
pas savoir où le mettre il faut écrire
votre m'en veux un peu à peu et à mesure
que vous vous rendez compte des
différents passages des clés des
cliffhanger des différentes clés qui
apparaissent pour vous discrètement vous
revenez en arrière et vous dites tiens
là dans cette phrase là dans cet échange
là dans ce dialogue noyé dans le
dialogue d'une page ou deux baffes
il ya le mouiller à la phrase qui dit
tout et qui est passée inaperçue parce
qu'au milieu du reste
[Musique]
moi ce que j'aime c'est qu'hier sans
plan justement parce que ne pas avoir de
plan ça me donne l'impression d'une
liberté totale ne pas être cadrée de ne
pas avoir besoin de suivre un schéma
précis et de pas avoir de plan ça me
permet d'imaginer ou de penser à des
aimants auxquelles je n'aurais pas pensé
de revenir en arrière et de modifier
autant que je veux j'ai l'impression
qu'un plan on passe énormément de temps
à créer ce plan est qu'une fois qu'on
l'a créée on se borne à le suivre et on
aurait parfois envie de changer de
renoncer de modifier mais on se dira
mais j'ai passé six mois ou un an à
écrire ce plan il faut que je le suis il
faut que je respecte ce plan c'est pour
ça que je préfère ne pas avoir de plan
et me laisser guider par mon envie alors
évidemment c'est peut-être parfois un
peu plus long ça demande plus de travail
parce que quand on n'a pas de plan on
prend des décisions qui sont peut-être
pas les bonnes mais on s'en rendent
qu'on se rend compte au bout de
cinquante pages il faut revenir en
arrière il ya ces moments où on se dit
mais je vais devoir couper 50 pages de
mon livre c'est pas très grave
quand moi quand genre tu ranges les
pages je me rends compte qu'en fait ça
signifie que le roman avance dans une
direction et ça c'est un sentiment assez
agréable
[Musique]
en bon roman policier c'est un roman qui
est avant tout à une atmosphère à
quelque chose qui permet aux lecteurs de
s'installer durablement dans le livre et
qu'il n'est pas forcément lié au crime
pas forcément lié à l'intrigué mais qui
est vraiment lié aux décors aux
personnages à l'univers dans lequel le
lecteur à se plonger et qui va donner
envie aux lecteurs de rester dans ce
monde là pour ensuite résoudre peu à peu
le crime mais l'énigme le meurtre enfin
ce qui se passe dans le roman policier
en question pour moi le meilleur roman
policier jamais écrit je dirais le crime
de l'orient-express agatha christie
pourquoi alors ça c'est aussi ma
relation de lecteurs avec un livre et
chacun a la sienne
je me souviens quand j'ai lu ce roman je
les lui parce que mon frère devait le
lire à l'école donc je de m garçons page
est beaucoup plus de 10 ou 11 ans et je
me souviens émerveillé de l'ambiance du
train ce huis clos dans ce train cette
atmosphère dormir dans le train à vivre
dans le train pendant plusieurs jours à
voir ce meurtre qui ai commis forcément
par un passager et je garde je garde de
cette lecture un souvenir absolument
émerveillé non seulement pour
l'intriguent mais avant tout comme je le
disais pour la pour l'atmosphère et tous
ces personnages dans ce train
[Musique]
selon moi on crée un bon personnages
leur donnant une identité à ce
personnage et l'identité du personnage
elle se crée par le vécu donc ce
personnage doit avoir un passé il doit
avoir un passé qui explique pourquoi il
est ce qu'il est au moment de l'action
pourquoi est ce qu'ils se comportent
comme ils se comportent qu'elles ont été
peut-être ces difficultés avant ses
relations avec les gens pourquoi est ce
que le personnage est célibataire ou
pourquoi est ce qu'il est marié et que
ça se passe bien ça se passe pas bien
mais il faut en général quand on donne
des informations
il faut que le lecteur puisse comprendre
pourquoi et je crois que ce pour quoi il
permet de rentrer dans l'intimité du
personnage parce qu'en général dans la
vraie vie quand quand on connaît bien
les gens on est capable de comprendre
leurs actions de même leurs actions qui
nous déplaisent où les actions avec
lesquels on n'est pas d'accord on est
capable de comprendre pourquoi ils se
comportent comme ils se comportaient ça
ça veut dire qu'on est intime avec ces
gens et je crois que c'est important que
le lecteur se sentent intime avec les
personnages
moi quand je commence un livre je
m'installe dans une ambiance qui me
plaît à moi je crée une atmosphère qui
me plaît à moi et ça c'est un élément
qui est très important parce que comme
je le disais avant
c'est important de vivre l'expérience de
l'écriture comme une expérience qui vous
apporte quelque chose à vous auteur ça
c'est la première étape c'est une table
qui est très importante et qui se
termine au moment de la fin de
l'écriture du livre étape 1 le processus
d'écriture il vous a plu vous avez eu du
plaisir ce plaisir il est à vous
personne ne peut le reprendre ensuite la
deuxième phase est ce que les gens vont
aimer votre pâques c'est une autre phase
qui ne doit pas ternir la première étape
qui est l'écriture de livres en gros
prenez du plaisir c'est l'élément le
plus important prenez du plaisir parce
que le plaisir dans l'écriture c'est un
plaisir qui est à vous c'est un moment
qui vous a fait du bien qui est avoué
que personne ne peut vous prendre
et puis n'oubliez pas de lire aussi la
lecture et l'écriture sont des choses
qui vont de pair lise elysées autant que
vous pouvez et je profite de dire la
lecture c'est pas forcément un moment
qui nécessite de prendre une soirée
entière se dire je bloque trois heures
pour lire maintenant c'est la lyre
savoir un livre avec soin dans la poche
dans le sac et lire quand on est dans le
bus quand on est dans le métro quand on
est chez le médecin que il ya une
attente 5 10 minutes
lire c'est prendre ces cinq dix minutes
qu'on a creuse ici là chaque semaine
chaque jour on a quelques minutes par ci
par là et qui sur l'ensemble de la
semaine et du mois font quand même pas
mal de temps ensemble donc ayez un livre
avec vous lisez vous allez voir que
c'est une occupation pendant les moments
creux de notre journée absolument
extraordinaire est bien supérieur à
notre téléphone portable
[Musique]